- He jumps up.
"You want some?!" Like, Deebo. You want some too?"
I'm like, "No, I don't!"
Ladies and gentlemen,
please give it up
for Ed Reed.
[Applause]
My man. What's up, baby? How you doin'?
- I'm good, man. No complaints, man.
Oh, I scratched on the first one. Damn.
- I gotta ask you:
So you, you're a guy who grows up in the
New Orleans area.
It feels like you were born to play football.
Why did you choose Miami?
- Y'all might wanna stand up and look and
say, "Why not Miami, right?"
Go stand by them stairs, man.
I wanted, I wanted to win a national
championship, and thank God we did.
You know, I actually got my ring on right
here. You know, so that, that's what it was about
to me, man. It was about playin', playin'
at the highest level, but putting myself in
position to also make it to the NFL.
You know, I was a businessman at a young age, man.
Just a little touch.
What was it like bein' the man on campus
and the man in Miami?
We partied after the game.
We can get—you can do whatever you want after
the game, but that week, man, just chill out.
- I gotta ask you about one specific moment while
Word on the street is you and Shannon Briggs—
- Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Had a little somethin' somethin' happened.
What happened that night?
The class of '95.
I'm class of '97. Class of '95 was known as Two Gs cuz
they graduate in 2000.
- So, it's me and Bryant McKinnie.
Bryant McKinnie and I are the youngest ones with
them hangin' out, and we're on the beach.
We're in the club, and one of the older guys come back
in like, "Y'all gotta come on! Let's go!
Let's go!
Um, "One of our teammates just got knocked
out!" Like, "Knocked out?!"
"Yeah, he got in a fight.
Let's go!"
So we like, "All right."
As we comin' through, I'm actually in the front.
So I'm lookin'. I'm like, "So, what's up, man?"
Like, "Why y'all jumped on our boy?"
"Why, you know, why you knocked him out?"
And lo and behold, he jumps up.
"You want some?" Like, Deebo.
"You want some too?
I'm like, "No.
Who is Shannon Briggs, man?
Shannon Briggs was a boxer.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
A champion boxer.
- Word?
- Very elite boxer.
- How big we talkin' here?
- Man, Shannon, Shannon Briggs, I mean, when
he stood up, he looked like King Kong, but—
About 6'5".
- That's a big-ass dude.
- But he's huge, man.
Solid, too.
but I got a bunch of cats with me, so."
Bryant McKinnie come through.
- Bryant McKinnie is, like, 6'9", 300-something at
this time. Needless to say, Bryant McKinnie
didn't give up a sack in Miami.
So Bryant McKinnie comes through. "Wait, wait, wait!
Get the—"
He was like, "Get the little guy."
So there's two of them, Shannon Briggs in
I come around, or whatever. Hit the little guy.
He's pretty much outta there.
Bryant, Bryant grabbed Shannonn Briggs by his
dreads. Yanks him down like he's Dwight Freeney.
He's on the ground, man. And they just,
they whalin' on him now.
I mean, they are goin' to town on him, right?
And he's just on the ground on his all
fours just takin' it. "Ooh, ooh."
Right?
So I go over there.
By the time I get over there, man, this
guy's just took off runnin' outta the group.
He's gettin' kicked, all kinds of stuff, right?
So we go back in the club. I'm like, "Man, I'm done.
I'm ready to go home now, man."
We gotta find our boy though.
So we finally get him.
We're on—
we're, like, Collins and 17th.
- So how far is that from here,
right in this location
we're in in South Beach right now?
We're on 17th right now.
Like, this is 17th. We're, like, right here, and he's at
Nikki Beach.
Nikki Beach is, is um, Ocean and 1.
You know, Ocean and 1st.
And you like, "What—how do you get down
there that quick?"
He ran down there, dude.
Like, Shannon Briggs kicked your ass.
You know, so that, I mean, that's kinda
how it happened, man.
That next day, dude, we had practice.
We walkin' out there sore. Like, we got in a boxing fight.
We didn't know that it was Shannon Briggs at the time.
You know what I'm sayin'?
Until he actually got sued by my boy
cuz he broke his jaw.
You know, you can't—boxers can't fight on the street.
Those are weapons, you know, so he wound
up gettin' sued and everything.
You know what I'm sayin', so.
- So, needles to say, are you cool with
Shannon Briggs now?
What's the relationship—
- I never even met him man!
Never even saw him after that.
And I hope you not watchin' this right now.
Thanks for kickin' it with us.
Subscribe to B/R
for more dope videos like this one.